zuallererst stellt euch einmal vor wir
sind kurz vor der bundestagswahl
und irgendwo an der autobahn in bayern
oder in nordrhein westfalen da gibt es
stände und da werden utensilien von
angela merkel verkauft genauso ist das
hier in den usa
wir beobachten das eigentlich jetzt seit
mehreren wochen dass wo immer wir
hinkommen ist diese mager geschäfte und
marga läden gibt mit völlig
unterschiedlichen dingen also wir haben
da ein mal den klassiker mac america
trade ecken kennen wir jetzt seit vier
jahren dann haben wir hier unten stand
for the flag also der große patriotismus
die amerika fahren dann was wir hier
auch immer wieder erleben und sehen der
bezug zu jesus der bezug zur bibel jesus
twenty twenty trump und jesus sozusagen
als erlöser hier oben auch eine
kernbotschaft von dem trump lager
blulife matter die anlehnung an die
polizei man steht hinter den
sicherheitskräften
man steht hinter der polizei man steht
hinter dem militär christian wir zeigen
noch einmal ganz kurz hier viele viele
camouflage caps auch weil natürlich
trump hat eine große basis unter den
soldaten groß und viel hinterhalt und
die sind hier sozusagen auch vertreten
und dabei so und jetzt gehen wir mal zum
stand hin zu kevin kevin hat seit vier
wochen diesen stand hat er uns gesagt
business days ausverkaufs am 10
was ist das spitzenprodukt zeigt uns
jetzt was am allermeisten verkauft und
weg geht
trotz des was ist ein tram train
da geht es nicht um einen echten zug
sondern es geht um pickup colón um
schiffe und boote alles menschen die
sich anschließend dieser trump bewegung
anschließend gemeinsam mit fahren
autokorsos machen über highways über
straßen
wir haben die bilder gesehen da sind 95
mainzer straße gesperrt worden wir haben
brücken in new york gesehen worden
die sind vom tram train genau
geschlossen und gesperrt worden
ja und das sind die produkte die es hier
gibt ich weiß nicht julian patricia
klaus kann ich euch etwas mitbringen hat
irgendein wünsch
danke sehr nettes du da an uns denkt
dabei werden noch eine frage nicht eben
gerade das erste für die republikaner
sieht es gut aus in arizona ist dass
auch der eindruck den du dort in den
vergangenen tagen ja wir machen konntest
auf einen fan stand sie zumindest ganz
so aus arizona ist trump land punkt aber
umfragen haben eigentlich in den letzten
wochen und in den letzten monaten ja
anzeichen gegeben dass arizona kippen
könnte was ein kleines politisches
erdbeben hier in der wüste wäre wäre das
erste mal eigentlich seit bill clinton
dass man hier blau werden würde aber
dann muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen unser
persönlicher eindruck hier aus den
letzten drei wochen
trump tram die menschen sind überall die
menschen sind laut es sind viele
menschen und auch heute morgen bei
unserem wahllokal auch das im vergleich
zu deutschland eigentlich undenkbar die
hälfte hatte tram t shirts an hatte
trump sticker dabei und hat damit klar
gemacht für wen sie stimmen insofern das
würde sich dann decken mit den zahlen
die da vielleicht anfangen über die
ticker zu laufen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren